they telling me to lay on the ground  it's just it was a bad situation people  are driving past looking at me like I'm  my animal my criminal I did something  what I'm an innocent bystander and  that's the big message it's the message  is you can be innocent as a black person  not doing anything totally unassuming  you're totally innocent and you can  still get mess with as long as you have  this in America you can get mess with we  should never have to feel like our lives  are in danger when we're doing regular  human activities I don't want to have to  fear for my life when I'm going to hold  foods and get me some get some chips and  guac or picking up a kombucha I don't  want to feel like my life is gonna be  sacrificed when I gotta go to the gas  station I'm pumping some gas and I'm  standing out there and a cop comes  rolling past and I don't know I should  not feel this way when I'm trying to do  regular human activity